>>> WELL, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WANTS TO HEAR FROM FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
THIS IS ACCORDING TO PEOPLE
FAMILIAR WITH THE MATTER.
PROSECUTORS REACHED OUT TO
PENCE'S REP HOPING TO GET THEIR
TESTIMONY IN THEIR CRIMINAL
PROBE OF TRUMP'S ATTEMPTS TO
STAY IN POWER AFTER THE
ELECTION.
PENCE HAS INDICATED HE IS OPEN
TO TALK ABOUT THAT, POSSIBLY
GIVING TESTIMONY.
MAGGIE, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
PENCE HAS ALWAYS CALLED THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE PARTISAN,
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE THOSE TWO
REPUBLICANS ON IT AND HE DOES
SEEM TO BE STAYING OPEN TO
TALKING TO THE COMMITTEE.
DO YOU THINK HE WILL?
>> I THINK HE'S MORE RECEPTIVE
TO THE D.O.J. BECAUSE HE
RECOGNIZES THERE'S A DIFFERENT
BETWEEN A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THIS HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE.
WHETHER THERE WILL BE SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
WE'RE A LONG WAYS AWAY FROM
THAT.
WE DON'T REMEMBER WHETHER IF
THERE'S AN AGREEMENT TO TESTIFY
F
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP CLAIMS
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
HAPPY THANKSGIVING.
>> HE ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK --
>> HE DID NOT ANNOUNCE.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
ALL OF THESE INVESTIGATIONS,
MIKE PENCE POSSIBLY TESTIFYING,
YADA, YADA, YADA, WHAT DOES ALL
THIS DO FOR TRUMP?
DOES IT MATTER?
>> I THINK IT DEPENDS, DON, ON
WHAT MIKE PENCE WOULD SAY BUT
MIKE PENCE IS A KEY WITNESS WHO
IS ONE OF THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO
WOULD SPEAK TO EVENTS IN THE
LEADUP TO JANUARY 6th.
THIS WOULD CREATE SUCH AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION, A
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT AND
POTENTIAL CANDIDATE, POTENTIALLY
TESTIFYING OR BEING INTERVIEWED
AGAINST A FORMER PRESIDENT WHO
IS A CANDIDATE, ALL OF THIS
BEING INVESTIGATED BY A JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN AN ADMINISTRATION
WITH A SITTING PRESIDENT WHO IS
LIKELY TO RUN AGAIN.
SO WE ARE JUST UNCHARTED
TERRITORY.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT ALASKA AND
SARA PALIN?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE DARLING OF
THE PARTY?
SHE'S LOST TWICE.
>> ALASKA IS A STRANGE STATE.
CUP GET CROSSOVER VOTES WITH
DEMOCRATS AND INDEPENDENTS.
IT'S AN UNUSUAL SITUATION.
BUT LOOK, I THINK SARAH PALIN
HAD A MOMENT IN TIME.
I THINK SHE HELPED USHER THIS
NEW PARTY AND I THINK DONALD
TRUMP INHERITED SOME OF WHAT SHE
BROUGHT IN BUT AT A CERTAIN
POINT YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO WIN
ELECTIONS AND TO KEEP SAYING
YOU'RE GOING TO WIN AND YOU'RE
STRONG AND YOUR BRAND OF
POLITICS IS STRONG AND TO NOT
WIN IS GOING TO RAISE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
THAT'S THE SAME QUESTIONS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
FACE.
>> THIS IS SOMEONE WHO TRUMP
VEHEMENTLY CAMPAIGNED AGAINST.
SHE VOTED TO CONVICT HIM DURING
THE SECOND IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AND
VOTED AGAINST A NUMBER OF KEEFE
THINGS IN HIS PRESIDENCY.
BUT WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING ABOUT MURKOWSKI
WINNING IS THIS SORT OF
COALITION THAT SHE BUILT ACROSS
THE AISLE IN ALASKA.
>> I THINK THAT MURKOWSKI IS A
WELL LIKED POLL SIGITICIAN IN T
STATE, THAT SHE'S SEEN AS
DELIVERING TO ARE THAT STATE.
AND IN D.C., EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
NOT IN D.C. BUT WE COVER D.C.
AND I THINK FOLKS THAT ARE IN
D.C. AND AROUND IT TEND TO BE
MORE REMOVED FROM THE DELIVERY
OF SERVICES OF GOVERNMENT.
SHE'S SEEN AS BEING EFFECTIVE AT
THAT GENERALLY SPEAKING AND THAT
IS WHAT LETS YOU WIN IN SENATE
RACES OFTEN IS WHAT LETS YOU WIN
IN GOVERNORS' RACES AND IT'S HOW
YOU BEHAVE IN CONNECTION WITH
THE SERVICES PEOPLE WANT.
I THINK THAT BRAND IS BASED ON
SOMETHING SUBSTANTIVE.
>> AGAIN, I KEEP GOING TO WHAT
IT PORTENDS FOR THE FUTURE,
RIGHT, BECAUSE WE HAVE THE MID
TERMS BEHIND US AND YOU HAVE
SOMEONE LIKE SENATOR MURKOWSKI
WHO IS -- I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
SHE IS MODERATE.
I WONDER IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IS ACTUALLY LISTENING TO THE
VOTERS BECAUSE YOU HAVE KEVIN
McCARTHY OUT THERE SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO DO THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, YOU HAVE HUNTER
BIDEN, YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE
THINGS.
NOT TO SAY THAT INVESTIGATIONS
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN BUT ARE THEY IN
TUNE WITH WHERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE STAND RIGHT NOW AND WHAT
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN, WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM?
>> I THINK THAT KEVIN McCARTHY
IS GOING TO GET SQUEEZED ON TO
ENGAGE IN A LOT OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS WHETHER HE WANTS
TO OR NOT.
WHETHER THAT IS WHERE THE PUBLIC
IS I THINK IS AN OPEN QUESTION.
I THINK WE HAVE CERTAINLY SEEN
IN PREVIOUS, YOU KNOW, YEARS AND
IN PREVIOUS CONGRESSES WHEN
CONGRESS IS PERCEIVED AS
OVERREACHING ON CERTAIN
INVESTIGATIONS AND WHETHER THEY
GET TOO PERSONAL.
I DO THINK THERE IS AN APPETITE
AMONG THE PRETTY WIDE CROSS
SECTION OF REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE FOR ACTIVITY AND
INVESTIGATIONS RELATED TO BIDEN.
I'M NOT SURE HOW WIDE THE
APPETITE IS FOR INVESTIGATIONS
RELATED TO INVESTIGATING THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE ALREADY BY
THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
JANUARY 6th.
THAT'S ANOTHER QUESTION McCARTHY
IS GETTING PRESSURED ON BY SOME
CORNERS OF THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
GROUP.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S A
HUGE OPEN QUESTION BUT BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS DID NOT GET THIS
OVERWHELMING WIN IN THE MID
TERMS, I DO THINK THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO FACE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF MANDATE THEY ARE
TAKING THE GAVEL WITH.
>> IMPORTANT QUESTION, MAGGIE
AND THIS BEHIND THE SCENES HERE.
EITHER YOU'RE AN ALL--IN
THANKSGIVING EVERYTHING OR
YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
CHINESE RESTAURANT SO WHERE DO
YOU STAND WITH THIS?
>> I AM COOKING A LOT.
>> SEE, SHE DOES IT ALL.
SHE DOES IT ALL.
>> IT'S AN UNEXPECTED SITUATION
BUT I'M COOKING EVERYTHING.
>> WOW.
SO BRING US SOME SAMPLES
TOMORROW.
WE WOULD LUKE SOME LEFTOVERS AND
WE WILL RETURN YOUR TUPPERWARE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US ON THIS